Hey oceans eight this is how you do that
[Music]
widows so widows is a new movie directed
by Steve McQueen director of 12 years of
slave it's a movie based on a novel
written by Gillian Flynn who's the
author of gone girl so all that comes
together for me to be like that's
probably gonna be a sweet movie the
opening plot that you mostly find out
through flashbacks is there's a group of
guys they're thieves they're led by Liam
Neeson they do a job it goes bad they
die but the ones they stole from her
like no no they stole money and we're
still owed that money we're gonna go
after Liam Neeson's wife for who's
played by Viola Davis so her in the
group of widows they get together and
they're like we need to do this job we
need to get the money let the mayhem
begin and I really dug this movie like
from the get-go from this startup it's
intense it just draws you in it starts
out with a really intense makeout
session where I'm like they're men
they're sucking face the audience was
just laughing and then it flashes to the
chase scene and everyone was like oh
[ __ ] movie just draws you in I just love
the sound editing is one of those movies
where when this sounds going down when
the cars are screeching when the guns
are going off it's [ __ ] intense and
Viola Davis is just a boss she's great
and everything she was great in Suicide
Squad to come on the movie all you want
but she's still grating it giving her
material okay like raúl juliá crushes it
in street fighter you know it's not just
her the whole cast Michelle Rodriguez
was really good Lana give some special
love to Elizabeth debicki debicki my
point is I'm used to her being like the
pretty one in this movie the hot one in
this movie one of the perfect people in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 this one
requires a lot more from her she totally
delivers Daniel Kaluga [ __ ] this dude's
great he's super into he's like the kind
of villain Woody Harrelson can play
where he's just staring at you and
you're like I'm unsettled please stop
this dude is an intense dick kind of
villain which is funny because he
started out playing good guy then
conflicted guy who fights for the
villain now full villain but the
villains in this movie too scary they're
unsettling and they're the right kind of
pressure to be like I could see why they
need to do this job now this movie being
a heist movie and I referenced oceans
eight already I'll mention it again
since the oceans movies really revolve
around the big heist is the point this
heist is very in and out it's more the
planning phase it's more than being
intimidated reacting to it like alright
what are we gonna do how are we gonna
deal with this how are we gonna deal
with our lives they're not good at being
thieves they're not criminals they're
Bin's worse so they're kind of winging
it sometimes they pass sometimes we fail
it's a very fish-out-of-water crime type
of movie that's one of the elements that
makes this movie feel very realistic so
when the heist is kind of just an
in-and-out kind of thing you never feel
let down by the fact that the job in the
end is really quick because the movie
nerve feels that extravagant the movie
feels real so I imagine the heist
wouldn't be too extravagant this movie
does have a lot of cogs turning edit a
lot of informations coming at you a lot
of players in this game gangsters
politicians working together mass
hysteria not all of the arcs really tie
up like Colin Farrell plays a politician
in this movie he's important to apply
pressure to his opposition who in turn
applies pressure to the protagonist he's
an important role is just not a big role
there are a couple scenes in this movie
one in particular I was like that was
the scene was kind of dumb the dude in
the scene was dumb and it does make the
fact that every dude in this movie in
the words of the great team America
World Police they're all dicks [ __ ]
or [ __ ] the student this scene was
like next-level stupid like dudes aren't
actually that stupid are they all right
feel like I wouldn't be if that happened
I'd be like no no you're not kissing me
who the [ __ ] are you but this was a
legit enjoyable crime heist movie and in
this case the heist doesn't make the
movie it's the characters I was invested
also the attention to detail there's
this one little detail this thing that
happens when they're punching in a code
it was just like that's just smart you
didn't have to make it go that way but
he just made it all the more intense
what was really enjoyable worth watching
and worth buying on blu-ray I just
really liked the fact that this movie
gave them something cool to do the movie
didn't make them rob jewelry from a
fashion show you know like girls do
that's what it seems like right and oh
she's a Robin necklace from a fashion
show it just sounds like someone was
like alright we got to make a heist
movie you know another oceans movie but
it's gonna have all women so I don't
know what a girl's like jewelry you know
chicks like jewelry great we'll have him
steal some jewelry but the women I know
are like I want to see women rob Vegas
that's cool women want to do the cool
[ __ ] that dudes do in movies Robin Vegas
is cool stealing a necklace from a
fashion show not maybe don't believe me
reverse it could you see if they made
oceans 14 with George Clooney and Brad
Pitt be going alright we got the next
job we're gonna steal jewelry from a
fashion show know anyone brought that to
Daniel Ocean he'd be like get the [ __ ]
out that's not cool sure the money's
fine but that she's not metal granted
they stole a pretty blinged out egg in
Ocean's Twelve but Ocean's Twelve was
also asked oh there is that so if it's
too lame for Daniel Ocean
his crew why is it not too lame for
Sandra Bullock and hers I just feel like
the mindset there was like but girls
like that [ __ ] why not just have them
steal a loot box from a Barbie Factory
why not have the cover be like ocean's 8
with a bunch of hearts that's what it
felt like but all that does is
compartmentalize it's like you're
walking down the aisles of Toys R Us
rest its soul Hawai I all over here girl
il over here he creates boxes in which
the boys have to go here the girls have
to go here because you made that one
awesome and you made that one weak sauce
because you think girls want that [ __ ]
and I just don't think that's the way it
is Hollywood could be screaming about no
female representation all they want but
in the end having Daniel oceans sister
and her friends still a necklace from a
fashion show just felt like a pat on the
head like that's what girls like jewelry
that'll shut him up and now they want to
do cool [ __ ] like this I bring this up
because when those weak-ass movies get
made and then someone reviews it on
YouTube or talks about it out there on
Twitter or something and they were like
oh yeah that all female lead cast movie
sucked I see a lot of people like fast
and it's not like the movie sucks the
genitalia of your cast doesn't make it
good or bad with those was just a
kick-ass movie that anyone could be in
of any gender it just happened to be
women any dudes would be happy to be one
of the ones doing the heist and widows
no dude wants to be in oceans eight
that's a lame-ass job alright tangent
over rant over all right so widows have
you seen it what did you think about it
or what did you think of you know my
thoughts on oceans eight versus this
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]